troisième verre ce soir mettez-le sur mon onglet vous
buvez aussi rappelez-vous
oublier de donner une merde ne vous donnera pas un
meilleur pourboire ne peut pas aider l'autoroute toute ma
famille a été tuée dans un accident de voiture
quelqu'un a fait des expériences horribles sur moi je
connais cette merde de super justicier  continue de
venir vers moi
savez-vous Captain America
Je veux absorber les enquêtes sur les pseudonymes
vous ne voulez pas de moi vous voulez juste
éliminer la concurrence
Je ne prends jamais non pour une réponse à quel point
quelque chose s'est passé derrière ces
portes  et
ils sont profonds, le simple fait de savoir ce qui vous a été
fait pourrait vous aider nous avons été créés ici
moi et quelque chose d'autre la seule façon de le
trouver est d'ouvrir la porte plus large
effet secondaire de puissance sont là comme moi laissez tomber il
y a un tueur que vous ne pouvez pas  contrôle je
n'ai rien demandé de tout cela
Jessica ne veut peut-être pas d'acolyte mais
elle en a besoin tu n'es pas super temps continue de
me dire qui es-tu
comment oses-tu
[Musique]
quel visage ça me rend pire que
vas-tu faire  je ne sais pas ça dépend  est sur
si je peux passer cette nuit sans
perdre ma merde
aujourd'hui il faut un monstre
pour arrêter un monstre
qu'est-ce qu'ils nous ont fait comme toi pour rester
un te garder à l'intérieur